Bei Sonnenstürmen wird aus der Sonnenatmosphäre
eine gigantische Wolke aus unvorstellbar heißem
Gas herausgeschleudert.
Die dabei ausgestoßenen Teilchen, Protonen,
können im Weltall Geschwindigkeiten von mehreren
Millionen Stundenkilometern erreichen.
Und es gibt noch weitere spannende Facts zum
Thema “Sonnensturm”, Wie gefährlich können
Sonnenstürme der Erde wirklich werden und
in wie weit sind wir vorbereitet Können die
Teilchen auch die Hülle eines Raumschiffes
durchdringen?
Die fünf spannendsten Facts über Sonnenstürme
bekommt ihr jetzt - viel Spaß dabei und herzlich
willkommen bei Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Abonniert den Kanal um kein Video mehr zu
verpassen!
Los geht’s
5.
Fact: Der heftigste Sonnensturm fand 1859
statt
Der Sonnensturm 1859 ging tatsächlich in
die Geschichte ein: Innerhalb von knapp einer
Woche Ende August/Anfang September passierten
mehrere starke Sonneneruptionen hintereinander.
Die ausgestoßene Materie erreichte nach etwa
17 Stunden die Erde und hatte eine Geschwindigkeit
von mehr als 2000 km/s drauf.
Die Polarlichter konnten selbst in Rom Hawai
und Havanna beobachtet werden.
Starkströme zerstörten Telegrafenleitungen
und das gesamte Netz wurde enorm beschädigt.
Dabei war es gerade erst installiert worden.
Dieser Mega-Sonnenstum wird übrigens als
das “Carrington-Ereignis” bezeichnet.
4.
Fact: Auch die ISS ist nicht wirklich sicher
Erst im vergangenen September musste die ISS-Besatzung
wegen eines gigantischen Protonensturms schnell
in Deckung gehen!
Am 4.
September 2017 hatte die jüngste Serie mit
schwachen Ausbrüchen begonnen.
Zwei Tage später folgte dann eine der stärksten
Eruptionen der letzten zwölf Jahre und gleichzeitig
eine der fünf heftigsten, die je auf der
Sonne beobachtet worden waren.
Daraufhin folgte dann ein Sonnenbeben - von
Forschungsteams auch “koronaler Massenauswurf”
genannt.
Solch eine Eruption hat die Energie von mehreren
Milliarden Atombombenexplosionen!
Jetzt konnten Forschungsteams auch herausfinden,
wo der Ausgangspunkt für die Eruptions-Serie
liegt: Und zwar am Rand der sichtbaren Sonnenscheibe,
der sich von der Erde wegdreht.
Die Besatzung auf der ISS bekam dann am 10.
September tatsächlich den Befehl “Alert”
also Alarm.
Daraufhin musste die Besatzung einige Zeit
in einem Schutzraum ausharren.
Zudem bekamen sie die Anweisung, weniger geschützte
Bereiche der Raumstation aufgrund der starken
Strahlung zu meiden.
Roskosmos, die russische Raumfahrtbehörde,
betont trotz allem, dass das alles eine reine
Vorsichtsmaßnahme gewesen sei.
Denn die ISS sei sehr sicher konstruiert.
Fest steht aber auch: Ein Teilchenschauer
kann ohne den Großteil der schützenden Wirkung
der Erdatmosphäre tatsächlich gravierend
sein.
3.
Fact: Polarlichter sind die “schönen”
Seiten der Sonnenstürmen
Ihr alle habt sicher schon mal Fotos von Polarlichtern
gesehen.
Oder sogar in echt.
Sie sind tatsächlich die “schönen” Seiten
der Sonnenstürme.
Denn durch den Eintritt der Plasmawolke in
das irdische Magnetfeld, werden elektrische
Spannungen in der Atmosphäre hervorgerufen.
Elektrisch geladene Teilchen werden beschleunigt
und dringen parallel zu den Feldlinien des
Erdmagnetfeldes tiefer in die Erdatmosphäre
ein.
Wenn sie dort auf das dichtere Atmosphären-Gas
treffen regen sie einzelne Gasteilchen zum
Leuchten an.
Wenn sehr starke Sonnenstürme das Erdmagnetfeld
enorm verformen, kann man Polarlichter dann
auch in Deutschland sehen.
2.
Fact: Sonnenstürme sind kaum vorauszusagen
Sonneneruptionen formen Plasmawolken und dadurch
entstehen magnetische Stürme in unserer Erdatmosphäre.
Das Problem: Solche Ausbrüche sind nicht
wirklich vorauszusehen.
Doch die Signale einer Sonneneruption erreichen
die Erde innerhalb von etwa acht Minuten.
Forschungsteams weltweit sind überzeugt davon,
dass uns eine solche Teilchenflut sehr gefährlich
werden kann - das hatten wir ja gerade schon
gehört.
Und dafür sind wir sehr schlecht auf einen
möglichen nächsten Sonnensturm sehr schlecht
vorbereitet!
Forschungsteams weltweit versuchen also notgedrungen,
über Statistiken heraus zu kristallisieren,
wie häufig und wie schlimm Sonnenstürme
uns in der Erd-Geschichte bereits getroffen
haben.
Radioaktive Baumringe legen beispielsweise
den Hinweis nahe, dass im Jahr 775 eine gigantische
Teilchenwelle über die Erde hinweg gefegt
ist.
Auch die Analyse des Lichts von knapp 150.000
sonnenähnlichen Sternen, konnte der Wissenschaftswelt
etwas über die Häufigkeit solcher Stürme
verraten.
Demnach könnten ähnlich heftige Sonneneruptionen
wie im Jahr 775 etwa alle 2000 Jahre auftreten.
Doch in Europa gibt es kaum Aufmerksamkeit
von seiten der Politik.
Anders dagegen in den USA: Da hat der Kongress
schon 2015 einen Aktionsraum zum Weltraumwetter
verabschiedet.
Notfallpläne sollen entwickelt werden und
das Stromnetz muss besser gegen Sonnenstürme
abgeschirmt werden.
Zwar sehen Teleskope und erdnahe Satelliten
den Ausbruch der Sonne, doch dann muss auch
eingeschätzt werden, wie stark er ausfallen
wird und ob er die Erde überhaupt treffen
wird.
Erst 20 Minuten, bevor der Sturm die Erde
erreicht, ist dann auch klar, in welche Richtung
sein Magnetfeld zeigen wird.
Und das ist entscheidend dafür, wie gut er
das irdische Magnetfeld durchdringen wird.
Derzeit spielen wir quasi russisches Roulette
mit der Sonne.
Wichtig wäre es also, die Prozesse auf der
Sonne besser zu verstehen, um sie dann irgendwann
einmal auch vorhersagen zu können.
Der europäische “Solar Orbiter”, der
Anfang 2020 aufbrechen soll, könnte dazu
enorm beitragen.
Fact: Gewaltige Sonnenstürme bedrohen uns
Menschen permanent
Sicher ist: Sonneneruptionen können auch
der Erde und uns Menschen sehr gefährlich
werden.
Selbst, wenn der Abstand zwischen Sonne und
Erde 150 Millionen Kilometer beträgt und
uns auch die Erdatmosphäre einen gewissen
Schutz bietet.
Denn Sonneneruptionen formen Plasmawolken
und dadurch entstehen magnetische Stürme
in unserer Erdatmosphäre.
Dann dringt Röntgenstrahlung in die Ionosphäre
ein und verändert die Eigenschaften so, dass
Funkwellen sich nicht mehr ausbreiten können.
Vor allem Kurz- und Ultrakurzwellen sind betroffen,
dort findet vor allem der Amateur und Mobilfunk
statt.
Auch GPS war von dem Sonnensturm im vergangenen
Herbst betroffen.
Sonnenstürme können aber auch fatale Folgen
für die Stromversorgung auf der Erde sein,
denn riesige Transformatoren könnten dann
gegrillt werden.
Die meisten von uns würden dann erst einmal
im Dunkeln sitzen.
Und es gibt weitere indirekte Konsequenzen,
die ein starker Sonnensturm mit sich bringt:
Ein Forschungsteam aus den USA hat beispielsweise
ermittelt, dass bis zu zwei Drittel aller
Amerikaner durch einen starken Sonnensturm
vom Strom- und Telekommunikationsnetz abgetrennt
werden könnten.
Der Schaden für die Wirtschaft und Infrastruktur
wäre enorm und beträgt den Schätzungen
zufolge acht bis gut 40 Milliarden US-Dollar.
Täglich!
Es gibt auch einige Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler, die die Sonnenausbrüche
mit Naturkatastrophen hier auf der Erde in
Verbindung setzen.
Taifune, Erdbeben und auch solche Hurrikans
wie “Harvey” und “Irma” könnten indirekt
Folgen von Sonneneruptionen sein.
Klingt logisch, wenn man bedenkt, welch eine
starke Energiequelle die Sonne darstellt.
Eruptionen sind nach Ansichten einiger Forschungsteams
zwar nicht der direkte Auslöser solcher Naturkatastrophen.
Doch selbst kleine Störungen der Sonnenaktivität
könnten lokalen Wetterbedingungen demnach
verstärken.
Klickt hier für unser Video: The End of The
Universe und Abonniert den Kanal für drei
neue Videos jede Woche!
Stay tuned and see you soon!